I know but you've been working and doing
some really good things and I'm glad I'm
glad I got you one here now because I
you you're big but I feel like you're
bout to blow up man did I not know not
as much as when we recorded this lat did
we recording this on a Saturday right
just a Saturday yes Saturday last night
Kawhi Leonard signed with the Los
Angeles Clippers dude magach to you man
I know you didn't stick you know with
the Clippers so I am admittedly I'm a
bandwagon fan man so the whole summer I
watch every NBA game I have League Pass
I'm on everyone's Twitter I watch all
the trade stuff right really just so I
know who to root for you know so it's
not like I'm invested the way that you
are I'm kind of like which storylines
exciting
cuz I like don't feel bad for
millionaires bandwagon a fan boney what
a bandwagon full so you know well I was
about to jump on and then boogie went
over to LA and I was like nah I think
I'm sticking with LeBron yeah you know
it's hard though cuz I'm a huge LeBron
James fan how do you love LeBron
I love LeBron James should I love
everything about him I love what he does
I love his rise I love like how he makes
every place a winner I love how people
hate him and how he comes back from that
so I don't know if Toronto could get a
championship I mean don't let the
Clippers win a championship it's gonna
be hard I mean but that Patrick Beverley
and Kauai and Paul joy that is like the
same defensive monster it's insane it's
a you know who's gonna get through that
and plus I just saw this stat Paul
George and Kawhi Leonard were in the top
five of efficiency four players in the
NBA last year like when they have the
ball in their hand do so it's like come
on it's a yeah but it's gonna be
terrible for comedy in LA though oh dude
or watching the games like I know when
the Lakers were good like doing like
that certainly right before the playoffs
whatever show was going on in LA
it's just ruined you know I've never
experienced that cuz the year I moved to
LA Lakers suck yeah it was because I
moved in 2012 it was like right when I
got here like 2011 they were still
making it at 2012
they were like it was falling apart at
the seams so I've never been here with
good l80 it's terrible it's you know
it's like it's empty you know you're
like what's going on lost Laker and now
with the playoffs is gonna be like dude
Clippers Lakers so now we got 82 games
you know in LA it's unreal 82 games
worth seeing yeah it's really exciting
even though I'm not a fan even though
I'm excited I'm not a fan of the
movement you know you want people to
stay where they're at
yeah I wanted to be like you know
they're compensated greatly to live in
Minnesota Shh
you don't I mean this isn't 1972 you
know were they only make it a little bit
of money and then like no they make you
make if I'm giving you 30 million
dollars [ __ ] you live wherever
the [ __ ] I say you live also you can get
a green tea latte anywhere I mean that's
the true you and you flying in the off
season all these NBA players from every
team in the league live in LA you know
so it's like I just I don't think that
to me personally like so LeBron James
started the whole thing as I move this
move this take power but he's not
qualified to run a fourteen billion
dollar business because that's what the
NBA is yet but you know a lot of these
teams are ruthless too though I mean
like did you see pressed he was gonna
trade Westbrook to Toronto he was just
ready to do it oh he was oh he was he
was ready to throw him in I mean that's
the guy that's like I'm Toronto I stayed
when Katie left they like start blowing
around I mean I'm okay see I see I see
they're gonna trade him to Tehran I'm
gonna send him to Toronto they were
trying to with the return Kauai to come
in Kauai there yes so they were gonna
trade Paul George and Westbrook over to
Toronto they were trying to get all
Toronto's picks through 2020 900 siakam
I thought it was gonna make more sense
for them to be like hey why don't you we
you know since you want Paul George why
don't we send them to Toronto that's
well that's what they were trying to do
but they were gonna throw in Westbrook
and then they were gonna get siakam and
like all their picks for 1000 Wow well
they got they got it they got a heist
from the Clippers though I know it's
even better deal than the Anthony Davis
deal
yeah Yanks are nuts well but they got
those picks because they traded Tobias
Harris to the Sixers yeah who got their
picks from you know all the [ __ ] that
they had done over the years yeah I mean
so it's like I know I love it's exciting
right now but yeah
excuse me this is what we missed out on
okay so when LeBron was in Miami and
then they beat San Antonio mmm by the
way because the Kawhi Leonard missed a
free throw
like his free throw miss is why they
lost that championship because they were
up three if he would have won they would
have been up for they would have won the
championship
then Ray Allen comes down hits death
three ties it out they win the next game
but anyway all right so they go we're
gonna run this back mm-hmm and then they
come back and a beat Miami mm-hmm that
was great mm-hmm that's gone now no one
runs it back you know yeah so uh Golden
State beats OKC I'm like this is gonna
be the rivalry of the ages this
[ __ ] goes to I will say though
all these guys now just signed some big
deals I think you're gonna have the next
three four years no one can go anywhere
you know I mean ad technically could I
think he'll resound with LA but you like
everyone can kind of do like everyone's
gonna be in their spot and and I think
we have westbrook's gonna be get traded
he's on a big contract though they were
talking about sending him to Miami which
would be insane you put my oh that's
gonna be great might be the thing
they're like wow I would love that would
make the east great Miami would
instantly vault into at least the top
five right I know cuz once KD comes back
that he still have some polish he's no
player in the history of the NBA except
for one player Dominique Wilkins
anything he wasn't a hundred percent has
come back from Achilles tear to be like
the player that they were I think to had
that with Wilkins was when he tore his
Achilles he was 23 23 to Saudi he's 30
or 31 yeah it's not but he's not an
explosive eclair
anyway the shooter so you might just end
up being like one of those like you know
set shot bill you know just you might be
on some like Dirk [ __ ] exactly obviously
most of the players in the league but
yeah I don't know I just I don't like to
move and I want to see like you know
build like I hope Milwaukee keeps the
Greek freak I hope that you know I mean
like they're already plotting maasai
taking him over to Toronto everyone's
like that's why I'm us I didn't trade
siakam because he's gonna have prime see
outcome and he's gonna get
giannis to come over I mean it's a I
don't know it's like fantasy basketball
all of a sudden that's why I'm a
bandwagon fan that's why I'm like I
don't feel bad for any of these
millionaires losing or moving or
whatever I'm just I'm in well you know I
started liking the Clippers back I used
to work at a grammar school this
Catholic school and one of the kids is
one of my it was like one of my favorite
players yeah I was a coach you know and
he like his mom worked at the Staples
not too stable said it was the Sports
Arena at the time he his mom worked at
the Sports Arena and then it was like he
goes hey coach you want to go to a game
mm-hmm and I was like what do you mean
he was like tickets to the game so I get
to the game we got these great seats and
I look at him I go you just telling me
this now was like 20 or whatever hell we
do not come to these games but then I
just became a fan I used to go to
clipper games all the time you grew up
in LA yeah cuz I would you grow up I
grew up in New Jersey New Jersey okay so
I wanted to go to I wanted to go to the
games cuz I was a fan of the SuperSonics
yeah so I wanted to go see Gary Payton
and Shawn Kemp yeah but then after a
while though you see you at the fourth
quarter you got to support the home team
yeah you know what I mean then you just
like I'm supporting the home team and
then I'm like okay I became a clipper
fan